so what's coming up is this thing called
the transit of venus uh and the reason
why it's a bit of an event is because
they're kind of they're not that
frequent although people may remember
there was one back in 2004 so you might
think well actually they are fairly
regularly but it turns up there are only
two and then there's a gap for almost
100 years and then another two so they
come you basically get them in pairs
every 100 years
and so if you miss this one you're gonna
have a pretty long wait for the next one
so a transit is just where one object
passes in front of another
and in this particular case the transit
of venus is just venus passing between
us and the sun and of course roughly
speaking you know that happens fairly
regularly because of course the various
planets all orbiting around the sun and
they sort of go you know they overtake
one another so once in a while uh
planets will kind of lie more or less
between us and the sun but because
things sort of wobble a little bit up
and down as well most of the time they
actually miss the disc of the sun and so
the rarity of this event is it just
happens to be right across the face of
the sun so it's not like an eclipse of
the sun where you know the moon happens
to have exactly the same angular size as
the sun pretty much so almost exactly
blots it out because venus is much much
smaller so all that will happen is a
tiny little black dot will trail across
the face of the sun this is one of those
cases where you have to put in all the
usual
take great care warning instructions
about this do not look directly at the
sun with the unaided eye do not whatever
happens look through the sun at the sun
through a telescope uh the only right
way of doing this is with the right
equipment which in this case means using
a pair of those glasses which are
actually designed for looking at the sun
and even then be careful because you've
got to check to make sure for example if
you've got one of those pairs of eclipse
glasses and it's got a tiny little
scratch in it that tiny little scratch
the sunlight streaming straight through
there could do serious damage to your
eyes so make sure that there's in date
they haven't expired and it actually
hasn't got any damage to it before you
look at the sun but if you do having put
all those caveats in if you have a pair
of those those sort of mylar glasses
that are designed for looking directly
at the sun you can actually with the
naked eye see the little black dot just
about of venus traveling across the face
of the sun sort of cuts a rather uneven
slice off one edge of the sun uh it
doesn't so sometimes again exactly where
it passes through the sun just depends
on uh on these relative locations of the
earth and venus so there's both i mean i
guess there's both historical science
and current science right the historical
science is that this was actually how we
figured out how big the universe was
bizarrely um so basically
you could figure out how far away things
were
relative to the distance between the
earth and the sun right so there's this
technique called parallax that allows us
to figure out from the little wobbles of
stars as you view them as the earth goes
around the sun how far that star is away
but that only works if you know exactly
how far the earth is from the sun okay
and so the transit of venus actually
gives a method for figuring out exactly
how far the earth is away from the sun
at least in principle and the way this
works is again actually down to parallax
that if you observe the transit of venus
at some point on the earth and you time
exactly when venus disappear you know
when venus starts crossing in front of
the sun and when it leaves and then you
go to a different place on the earth or
actually since you only get the one shot
to do this somebody else has already
gone to a different place at a different
latitude and
does exactly the same measurement
because they're viewing this event from
slightly different directions one higher
up on the earth the other low down on
the earth they'll actually see the
timings of these events slightly
differently and just from that
difference in timing that actually
allows you with them with a little bit
of trigonometry to figure out how far
the sun is away in terms of how far your
two observers were apart and because you
can measure distances on the earth that
then allows you at least in principle a
way of figuring out the distance to the
sun and hence the scale of the entire
universe so historically that's why it
was sort of important nowadays if you
want to figure out the scale of the
solar system there are much easier ways
of doing it you can for example just
fire a radar a pulse of radar at a
planet and wait for it to bounce back
and then the time it takes to travel
there and back tells you exactly how far
away the planet is so nowadays there are
kind of easier ways and much more
accurate ways of doing it but uh in the
sort of the 19th century when these
measurements were first being made
accurately this was the most accurate
way of figuring out the scale of the
solar system and hence then when you
use that to calibrate other measurements
the scale of the whole universe the
trick was to spread your your observers
out as far as you could so captain cook
made observations of this in tahiti
people went to the southern seas
there's lots and lots of stories of
there was some poor guy french guy who
actually went to the southern seas uh to
to observe the transit of venus the
first one was crack clouded out entirely
he knew that there would be another one
in eight years so he then hung around
there for eight years um second one he
actually made some observations but he
made them from a ship and the ship's
deck was heaving around so much he
didn't actually get any good data so
then he finally made his way back to
france and found that he'd been declared
dead in his absence and so there's
some scary stories that go along with
observing this it's a it has to be a
quite accurate measurement you make and
actually it turned out to be not as easy
to do as had been assumed because
there's a strange effect called the
black drop effect which as
as venus first so basically remember the
thing you need to do is measure very
accurately the time when the transit
begins when venus first starts to travel
across in front of the sun and this
weird thing the black drop effect means
that as venus approaches the sun it's
it's little disk if you're viewing it
through a telescope appears to get kind
of extended into a little droplet shape
almost a pear shape and so actually
measuring the price precise moment where
it first starts to disappear
in front of the sun is actually a very
hard thing to do because it's no longer
a nice perfect circular object anymore
and picking the exact moment when it
starts to travel in front of the sun
turns out not to be something you can
measure particularly precisely kind of
intrinsically
this is about the hardest time you could
possibly try to observe venus when it's
up against the the glaring brightness of
the sun you're much better observing
venus kind of at night when it's well
away from the sun but of course what
you're actually observing there that
transit is something that's being used
now to discover planets going around
other stars
and so these transiting effects we're
actually seeing the little dips in light
that occur when other planets travel in
front of of stars um stars other than
the sun
and so in principle this is kind of a
useful calibration point because we
already know a lot about venus to say
well can we make the same kind of
observation during a transit of venus
that we would make of another planet
going around another star using the
telescope you know elsewhere
now of course it's not quite the same
thing because the sun is blazingly
bright and actually the kind of
instrumentation you would use to detect
a transit in front of another star is
completely different
but nonetheless there's things that we
can learn and and there's been this
rather clever idea that someone's come
up with of rather than observing the sun
directly and seeing one of these
transits occurring they're actually
going to point the hubble space
telescope at the moon
and look at the reflected sunlight
because of course the light you see from
the moon is just reflected sunlight but
of course much fainter so you can point
the hubble space telescope at the moon
without doing irreparable damage to it
that you would if you pointed it at the
sun and they're going to try to observe
the transit of venus by pointing the
telescope at the moon and spotting the
little changes in the light from the
moon as venus transits across in front
of the sun this is an incredibly rare
astronomical event and you're an
astronomer
you're not going to get another chance
are you going to go are you going to
look at it it's a bit early in the
morning for me it's actually so from the
uk it's only visible it's the event
starts before sunrise and so as the sun
rises
in the uk the transit will already be
fairly well advanced and it's about an
hour left of the transit and so that's
about between about 4 30 and 5 30 in the
morning which is a bit early for me
there's not gonna be another one for 100
years it's a little black dot traveling
across the front of the sun